سيناريو مكرر كان بطله الاول الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب عندما تم
العثور على وثائق سريه في منزله بفلوريدا
اما هذه المره ورئيس الحالي هو بطل المشهد
بعد ان كشف محامو بيض عددا من الوثائق
السريه في مكتبه بمركز ابحاث في واشنطن
تعود للفتره التي استلم فيها منصب نائب
الرئيس
العشر لم يتم التاكد من سيرتها لكن قد يتم
اتهامه باساءه التعامل مع سجلات سريه ما
يخلق مشاكل للرئيس باي لانه هو في غنى
عنها وهو الذي خرج للتو من الانتخابات
التشديد المصري موقفا قد يدفع جمهوريه
مجلس النواب التي تدعمه مؤخرا بالمقار فيه
الى فتحي تحقيقا بحق بيضا ويؤثر على وزاره
العدل فيما يجب ان توجهاتهامات لترامب
الذي اعلنترشحه للا دلوقتي 2024
لايجاد الوثائق مؤكدا ان الديمقراطيين
بالغوا في موقفهم بالتعامل مع الوثائق
السريه في المنزل ترامب مقارنا مع موقف
بيضا
معه وقت اطول لم يكن ترامب في منصبه من
قبل وكان قد غدر للتو وخرج من منصبه
التروس متسائلا ما اذا كان مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدراليه سيداهم منازل بيض والبيت
الابيض حتى في اشاره لمداهمه منزله في
فلوريدا عمر العربيه